おはようございます朝8時
図3冊です青森からなにぶん君というちょっとユーチューバーの子が1人遊びに来てる
んですけども
昨日ちょっと飲んで飲んで寝ておりますぐっすり
今まで数々の寝起きドッキリべザマンスをしてきたんですけど今回はこちらブブゼラを
使おうと思ってます
これすごいちゃっ子様に見えてめちゃくちゃ音が大きくてで問題にもなったくらい
らしいです
1メートルほど流さなラッパの一種でスタジアム品とも呼ばれる
チェアほんの一瞬唇に当てて拭くだけでゾーンの巻声のような単調なしかし非常に
大きな音が出ると
部勢は127てシーベル同党を出すことから美味鮮の使用が推奨されて
いるくらい耳栓つけなきゃな形でなんかイベント通知音がでかすぎて腫瘍が金瀬なんで
止まるくらいちゃっちく見えて多分今までよりかなり危険な
かなり目指す的な言い方だと思います越前調査によりもストバディブックは米大きいと
聞いたされても起きるようなタイプじゃないらしい
撤回を出しても降誕ておきたいそこらへんねこの不是楽って
ができればと思っております
さああああああああああっ本当に女本当にでかいぞ
はぁっはぁもう本当によれば僕いうの朝の挨拶同じブックに西洋と思いますでは行こう
[音楽]
ああああああ
ん
me
おっん
持っています
ni
me
はあああああ
ああああああ
うっうー do
dee
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
主語
ずんハウスじゃん
大きい
ねっ
はあああ
はーい
あっはぁ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ウール